>> Okay.
Thank you all for coming.
Appreciate you being here.
It's my great pleasure to introduce George
Steinmetz, I've been a big
fan of his work for some time.
Amazing photographer and author of two books
now.
And welcome, George.
Thanks for coming.
>> [Applause]
George Steinmetz: Thank you.
Umm, I wanted to show you all some pictures
today from a long-term
project that I've been working on about the
world's deserts and I got
into this because when I was a young man and
I hitchhiked across the
Sahara Desert and I imagined what it would
be like to fly over the
desert.
And about 12 years ago I talked National Geographic
into doing a big
project in the Sahara and I wanted to aerial
photos and I got
into motorized paragliding to do that.
And when I was flying over the Sahara on that
first trip it opened up
my mind to a new way of seeing the world from
the air.
And I started to wonder what it would be like
if I took my crazy
little aircraft to different parts of the
world, umm, to other
deserts, to the Atacama, to the Gobi, to Antarctica,
which most people
don't think of as a desert but it is.
It's the world's largest desert.
And what I'm gonna show you are pictures from
that project and then in
the past six years I've actually been using
Google Earth a lot for my
research and trying figure out where to go
'cause I go to very remote
areas where there's -- most of these areas
have never really been
photographed before.
And so it's, uh, you have to find your subject
matter and it's very
difficult and expensive to get around so you
need to know where you're
going.
They call this project hyper-arid because
the areas we've been going
to are the driest areas on our planet.
They all get less than 10 centimeters of annual
percipitation.
This is in the dry valleys of Antarctica.
These are Victoria Dunes.
I was down there on a grant from the National
Science Foundation to
document their scientific research work there.
This is in the, umm, Atacama Desert on the
coast of Peru.
That's the Pacific in the background.
And, uh, this is up in the, umm, Qaidam Basin
in China on kind of the
backside of the Himalaya, the north side of
the Himalaya.
Uh, it's in the Gobi Desert in China.
These are the Badain Jaran Desert in -- these
are the tallest dunes in
the world.
They're over 1200 feet.
These are the sub dunes that are part of the
1200-foot dunes.
And this is in the Namib Desert in Namibia
southwest Africa.
And this is in Antarctica, also.
This is in the Dry Valleys.
This frozen lake is the purest water in the
world.
Umm, and this is out in the Empty Quarters
of Arabia.
Umm, the tracks on the right are the -- are
my car tracks and the
car -- car -- tracks on the left are 50 years
old.
The area is so sterile it's paralyzed landscape.
There's really no -- there's no life out there
at all.
And this is where the Empty Quarter bumps
into the United Arab
Emirates and this is a -- they tried to stabilize
the sand with
pumping ground water into a little drip irrigation
system.
This is the last steam train in the Gobi Desert
with a similar sand
stabilization program.
And this is in the -- this is the village
of Rendille people in
northern Kenya.
The area's now going through a severe draught
and the people have
moved to a mission post to get education,
access to water, and medical
care, but when they're in a sedentary village
environment they can't
feed their camels and their goats so this
is kind of their village and
town but most of their adult males and the
livestock was 10 to 15-miles
away trying to find grass for their animals.
And this caravan's carrying salt across the
Sahara.
Still do that.
This picture's about ten years old but they
still do.
This is in Iran.
These -- the holes are from underground aquaducts
that are thousands
of years old.
They have vertical shafts to clean them out
and they have to go down
every ten years or so to take out the mineralization
out of the canals
that take water from the highlands down to
the lowland farms.
This is a similar system in China.
The -- this Qanat system, the system of underground
irrigation spread
along the silk road from Iran all the way
to western
China and then you can find it on the other
side of the world in
Moracco.
World travel -- knowledge traveled by camel.
Umm, this is the road to the oil fields in
China, the Taklamakan
Desert.
You get a similar system of taking salty ground
water and putting it
through dip irrigation to make plants to stabilize
the dunes so that
the road doesn't get overtaken by dunes.
And the little blue house is for the person
who makes sure the drip
irrigation pipes don't leak.
This is the lowest point in China.
It's about 50 meters below sea level in the
Taklamakan in the tar pit --
And these pits are used to harvest salt.
These -- there's some prison labor out there.
Umm, that's harvesting peppers on the floor
of the Taklamakan Desert.
Put 'em out to dry.
And this is, umm, an area where they cultivate
salt in the Sahara.
It's for animals -- animal use.
And the different colors are because of the
mineral content of the --
of the mud.
They mix kind of salty mud with well water
and then they -- the -- the
white areas you see like, umm, that's from
salt forming on the surface
kind of like, umm, like ice forming on the
surface of a pond and they
splash the water up and then the ice -- sorry,
the salt will go down
to the bottom and after a month or so of this
process the whole basin will be filled enough
with salt they can scrape it out in their
little
mud-lined basins.
Umm, this is in, uh, central Sahara.
This is in northern Mali.
And there's a different salt trade from, uh,
some oases between Mali
and Algeria and they carry it down by camel
caravan to Timbuktu and
this is the only, umm, uh, the only, uh, consistent
water point so
there's a little village here where they trade
water for salt and the
village is half buried in the sand.
And there's no vegetation at all because the
camels have eaten
everything.
You go 10 miles away from the village and
you would find scrub
vegetation but within 10 miles it's all been
eaten by camel.
Inside of the Empty Quarter of Arabia.
Very unusual to have two colors of sand.
You have to have very strong winds.
Umm, and, uh, these are, umm, James's flamingos
in Bolivia.
And these are greater flamingos.
This is in Iran.
Flamingos are very skiddish birds but with
my aircraft I can get
fairly close to them.
Camels going out to get fodder on the Empty
Quarter of Arabia.
It's funny.
I started -- this picture went viral on the
internet about two years
ago and I started getting these strange e-mails
from people in the
Middle East. They thought it was taken with
a predator aircraft and
then they wanted to make sure it was -- they
thought it was, you know,
was I part of the CIA and how did I get this
picture?
And then I started getting e-mails from camera
clubs in the U.S.
because they wanted to know what camera lens
I took and it was just
funny.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: Different sides of the same
coin.
They all thought it was done in Photoshop,
too.
The central Sahara.
It's in northern Chad.
And this is in, uh, Namib Desert in the southwest
coast of Africa.
And zebras on a nature reserve in Namibia.
The circles there, they're very strange.
They called them fairy circles and they're
not really understood.
There's, umm, these kind of bald areas and
they suspect that it could
be some kind of toxic in the ground, maybe
an insect colony, like an
ant hill, the ants left some sort of toxicity,
or some kind of tree that
no longer exists that left some toxicity in
a decayed root system but
nobody really understands.
This is the, umm, end of the Colorado River
where it hits the Gulf of
California and Mexico.
Down river from calexico and you have 30-foot
tides here.
So this was taken in the morning of a full
moon when the tide was at
its lowest.
Used to be one of the most productive wetlands
in North America and
now it's just a sand desert raked by tide.
This is the Altiplano in Bolivia.
This lake is the biggest salt flat in the
world.
It's, umm, 12,000 feet.
And in the springtime it gets flooded.
Those are two cars -- my two cars -- the two
cars I hired take aroung and we use one for
the aircraft and one for camp supplies but
I wanted them for
scale to get an idea how big the Sahara was.
This is taken just after sunrise.
And this is also in the Altiplano.
This lake's about 14,000 feet.
Laguna Co -- Laguna Colorada with a indemnic
species of flamingo that
nest there, James's Flamingo.
This is Cape Vercillos on the southeast African
coast -- southwest African coast
in Namibia.
Most of the areas I go to there are virtually
no people there.
It's so severe.
Sometimes you find some unusual way that animal
life can exist there
but virtually no people at all.
This is the Antarctic coast near the Dry Valleys.
It's perma frost.
On the right there is the Ross Sea.
And this is the Niger River in northern Mali.
In the middle foreground is a mosque.
It's taken during the flood season when everybody's
growing rice.
And this is, uh, the north side of the Himalaya
in the Qaidam
Basin in China.
This is all deserts of Iran.
It's very difficult getting permission to
fly over there.
And that little white parachute that's what
I fly.
It's my friend Alaranu's.
He's gone with my on just about all my trips.
He's the world champion of this crazy kind
of aviation.
And a similar pattern in -- this is where
glaciers come together in
Antarctica is they head out into the Ross
Sea.
The black is all glacial till.
The rocks that got ground up as the glaciers
move them and as they merge it gets kind of
tossed up on the surface.
And this is in the Lut Desert in Iran.
It's kind of a rock formation called yardangs.
They're wind weathered rocks.
This is biggest field of yardangs in the world.
It's an old, umm, lake deposit.
When you have really severe rains from one
direction it's kinda like
sandblasting soft wood.
You get these kind of fluted ridges that pop
up and this is an area
that's, umm, frequented by heroin smugglers
'cause they can travel through
the desert without being seen and it was very
hard to get the Iranian
military police to take me out there because
they were worried about
getting shot.
Let alone having the crazy American taking
pictures of their terrain.
Got arrested three times over there.
Umm, this is out in the Altiplano in Bolivia.
This is edible salt being harvested for human
consumption.
And this is also in Iran in the salt deserts.
Lake Tashk.
Home to a lot of flamingos.
This is the Ross Sea in Antarctica.
It's a -- looking at the tongue of the Erebus
Glacier it comes out and
in the summer the wave action -- the winds
and the wave action will turn
the -- they carve the tongue of the glacier
into kind of a scallop pattern
from the -- kind of like the waves kind of
gnawing at the ice.
Looks like a big bill of, like, a sawtooth
shark.
It's another view of Mount Erebus looking
the other way.
Mount Erebus the big, uh, volcano in the background.
There's a molten lava lake in the center of
that volcano.
One of only two in the world.
This is down to P-3 Orion from the U.S. Navy
crashed on take-off in
Antarctica.
It was overloaded.
You see Mount Erebus in the very background
on the left.
It's Arakao in Niger.
It's a crater that, uh, didn't quite erupt
and then it sank back down
and it was invaded by sand and wind off the
central Sahara.
Some of the fee -- this is one of the higher
altitude pictures I take.
Most of my flying is very low, like, umm,
a hundred to 500 feet but
for really large features like this volcano
you have to get up quite
high.
This is taken about 6,000 feet above ground.
The volcano is probably 5 miles across and
you can see a little pink
parachute in kind of the upper left and that's
one of my French
buddies that was flying with me in the same
aircraft that I had.
This picture's taken from the ground but at
21,000 feet, the top of
the highest point of Bolivia and at sunrise
Mount Sajama projects,
umm, projects a shadow out of the atmosphere
it's so tall.
Those two volcanos in the background, that's
the border between
Bolivia and, uh, and Chile.
This is also the Altiplano volcanic island
in the salt lake.
Salt flats.
This is in, uh, the Sonora Desert just south
of the U.S. border.
The red parachute's my crazy friend Alain
Anu and the winds are so
strong here and this is a ridge of salt and
Alain Anu was flying -- the
winds were so strong that he could actually
walk the ring as he was
flying and he said it was brick hard.
It looks like a sand dune but it was brick-hard
mud.
This is my legs above a volcanic crater in
Niger.
I think if you look at the altimeter my altitude
-- yeah.
I'm at 7,470 some feet and I was 5,500 feet
above take-off.
this really scared the hell outta me.
This was my first trip with the par -- with
the paragliding.
I've never been that tall.
It's really uncomfortable being that high.
It's actually -- it's quite safe but it's
very nerve wracking 'cause
if you drop anything it's gone.
I got a motor behind me.
If I drop it, it's gonna get sucked into the
propeller and the motor's
gonna go kaput and I'm -- you can see I'm
really far away from the
sand so I might not be able to get it back
to there and I don't wanna
land in this rough terrain.
And it's just -- it's -- it's -- yeah,
Unnerving for me being up that high.
This is in the same flight getting down low
it's a lot more fun.
Chasing Francois.
I'm taking off from the salt flats in Bolivia,
12,000 feet.
It's very cold.
You have to run a long way to take off at
12,000 feet.
And this, uh, flying over Shaybah.
They call it the Manhattan of the desert in
Yemen.
It's also known as the medieval Manhattan.
These buildings are, umm, eight stories tall
made of mud and palm
fronds.
It's the mosque in the middle that I'm about
to buzz.
And, umm, this is after I had a bad take-off
in China.
I got 19 stitches in my face.
But no mark.
>> [Upbeat percussion music playing]
>> [Wind chimes]
George Steinmetz: And so when I get to a place
there's some assembly
required and then -- and then this is how
our a take-off works.
This is in Yemen.
>> [Propeller/engine buzzing, wind blowing]
>> [Engine running, wind blowing]
George Steinmetz: The take-offs can be a little
tricky but flying's
actually pretty easy.
>> [Propeller buzzing in the background]
George Steinmetz: This is from the Empty Quarter
in Saudi Arabia.
Actually, this is Yemen.
>> [propeller running]
George Steinmetz: So, the trick is flying
and taking pictures at the
same time and it's, umm -- it takes a little
practice.
>> [Laughing]
>> [Propeller buzzing, wind blowing]
George Steinmetz: And from -- the sequence
from that little flight
resulted in this picture of Reem gazelles.
And before I go away on my trips I do a lot
-- I spend a lot of time
doing research, a lot of it on the computer
now, and I used to have to
hit up friends of mine at JPL for satellite
images but now actually I
use Google Earth 'cause now I don't have to
trade any favors and
it's -- it's really an amazing tool.
This is, umm, the border between -- on the
right side -- the right
side of the road is Oman and the left side
where the green is the
U.A.E.
This is what it looks like from the ground.
This is the border fence.
U.A.E.'s got a lot more oil money per capita
so they are much more
wasteful in their use of water.
And these are crop circles in Saudi Arabia.
And if you look at, uh, this little area right
here, this is a big
salt lake.
It would be a dune.
The dune used to be here and then it moved
as the lake dropped.
And so you have all the trees on the right
die because the water table
dropped about 5 meters and the trees that
are on the left are doing
just great.
These are, umm, star dunes in Yemen.
Very hard driving up there.
And this is in the Emirates.
There is a little -- this little city right
there, it's a medieval
fort.
It's been re-built.
Looks like that.
And this is a river coming out of the Atlas
Mountains out in the
Sahara and if you get there on the right day
-- it happens once about every
25 years or so -- you get snow.
It's very lucky to catch snow on the Atlas
-- on this part of the
Atlas.
Never seen snow on palm trees before.
This is in the coast of Mauritania where all
the camels got wiped out
in the draught of the 80s and now everybody
fishes.
And this is one of the few roads going across
the Empty Quarter in
Saudi Arabia.
And this is out in the salt deserts of Iran.
I don't know if many have studied the geology
but there are huge salt
domes, huge plumes of subterranean salt deposits
that have pushed
their way up like a molar coming up through
gums and the area got
inundated and the top was shirred off and
you have this pattern looks
like burl wood.
>> Is that a composite --
George Steinmetz: The Google Earth image?
>> (Asking question in the background.)
George Steinmetz: You can see there's a composite
line on the left.
Yeah.
And it's actually a lot more colorful in real
life.
This -- is actually happens to be out in a
military rocket range.
Very dangerous place to be flying an aircraft
like mine.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: Fortunately nobody found
out.
This is in the Empty Quarter of Saudi Arabia.
Composite image of, like, three or four different
digital globe images.
Also a very dangerous enviroment to fly.
It's kinda like -- they're kinda like sand
traps and if you -- if I
landed on one of those they could probably
get in there with a
vehicle.
We'd never be able to get out.
So there's one road going across it.
So it's -- it's a nasty place to be flying.
I can't -- I'm so light with my aircraft I
don't take anything.
Actually one camera, one extra lens, and no
water.
And so you really got -- you have a radio
and a GPS and you try to be
careful.
And these are very curious a kind of barchan
dunes with their propagating jelly
fish.
It's in Yemen.
And then so I'll spend hours late at night,
uh, trolling through
Google Earth and NASA images kinda like -- kinda
like going through along with
a magnifying glass looking for interesting
features.
And on the upper left is kind of a big zigzag
of sand and I thought,
ooh, that'd be cool.
And this is in LANSAT7 imagery.
You see the same zigzag.
It's not quite up in the same corner.
It's kinda halfway between the center point
and the upper left corner?
See the zigzag?
And then in the kinda lower right there's
a big lake and that lake is
caused by an oil well that was abandoned when
it hit a subterranean
fresh water aquifer.
So it's just kind of a big salty lake out
there and this big zigzag and I thought it'd
be kind of a cool thing to check out.
And the zigzag was quite cool but it's just
massive in scale.
You can see two of our cars out there.
It's one thing to see something like that
and say, cool.
It's another thing to be able to get out there
on the ground 'cause
the purple stuff is all sudka.
The salt flats that have mud deposit underneath
them you can be going
along and it's all dry and all of a sudden
your car starts sinking down in the mud and
if you get stuck out there, there's nobody
coming to get
you.
You're really stuck.
You couldn't even -- you couldn't get a helicopter
out there 'cause
they couldn't take off and land.
Too difficult environment.
This is in Yemen.
This is the same town you saw me flying over,
uh, a few images before.
This is Shaybah.
Medieval Manhattan.
>> [Silence]
George Steinmetz: This is not part of my desert
project but I went to
China for the geographic 'cause I wanted to
go to China's deserts and
I had to do the whole country.
And these are these weird, umm, very unusual
homes of the Hakka people.
They migrated from the north where they were
continually attacked by
nomads and so they started building circular
villages that were
fortified.
And as their population grew they kept -- the
villages grew like rings
in a tree.
But I couldn't -- I found these -- this site
through Google Earth.
Actually, the sites were listed in tourist
brochures but it was too
mountainous an area for me to fly.
This is great situation I just drove to with
Google imagery.
It was very helpful.
Uh, this is in the Great Rift Valley in Africa,
Lake Natron.
It's -- sometimes I work from a small plane
if it's too dangerous an
area to fly, like this area.
It's very caustic salts that are red from
algae growth and if you land
in there you get very bad burns on your legs.
And this is the Altiplano in Bolivia.
Similar pattern in salt.
Edible salt.
And my friend Alain Anu, the pilot, checking
out some cracked mud
between -- there used to be two dunes filled
by a lake and then the
dunes moved away and left kinda this -- kinda
looks like elephant
skin, uh, crack, uh, cracked clay on the surface.
This is mount Erebus in Antarctica.
The molten lava lake at the center of that
big cloud of steam.
That's the Ross Sea in the background that
the shadow of the volcano's
casting on.
The peak of edge of the Empty Quarter in Yemen.
This is in the central Sahara, in Chad.
Same place.
This is in the Namibian coast.
It's a freighter that went ground about 30
years ago and the ocean --
the beach has been accreting so now it's about
a half a kilometer
from the water.
The salt flats of Bolivia.
The coast of Peru.
The shore of a lake in Namibia.
It's clay.
It's a little stick.
This is not a -- this is a low altitude aerial,
about one meter.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: A cheater.
And this is, uh, over the, umm, the shanty
town of Nouakchott, the
capital of Mauritania.
No plumbing, no electricity.
It's all little donkey cart paths for water
and trade.
And this is out in the Sonora desert of Creosote
and in Creosote they space
each other out because of how much water their
roots need to -- to
survive.
Caravan crossing the Sahara.
This is the vegetable garden of Timbuktu in
Mali.
Center pivot irrigation system growing tomatoes
in Saudi Arabia.
They drill down into the fossil water that
underlies the desert.
This water filtering the last ice age and
the wells will last about 20
years until they've sucked all the water out
of the rock underneath
and then their abandoned.
But with water and fertilizer they can grow
tomatoes.
This is, uh, a very rare fog in the Empty
Quarter near the border of
Saudi Arabia with the Emirates.
Star dune.
It's the little dot in kinda the lower center
is our car.
And the ground's white because there was a
salty spring nearby that
stained the ground white.
This is in the Gobi Desert in China.
Tallest dunes in the world.
These dunes are about 1200 feet tall.
In between the dunes there are salt lakes
with fresh water margins.
That little green strip you see in the lower
left -- so sorry, lower
right -- you walked along that green strip
you could drink fresh water
out of your footprints, but to the right into
the lake it's saltier than sea water.
So the dunes act as kind of a reservoir for
fresh water that falls in
the winter.
This is in Iran.
This is out in the Gobi in China where they're
trying to
stabilize dunes that are taking over agricultural
fields.
This is Macor next -- this is a picture from
the Dead Sea.
This slide's from Israel in Jordan and this
is a site called Macor in
Jordan where John the Baptist had his head
cut off and delivered to
Herod's wife for her birthday.
Or so they say.
This is Masada, in Israel.
And that big, uh, kinda -- in the middle center
is a big ramp that the
Romans used to overtake Masada.
This is a military area in Jordan.
Controlled access 'cause they don't want Palestinians
to be crossing
in -- crossing the Dead Sea.
And the Dead Sea is sunk so low that part
of it's actually totally dry
so they pump water up and there's a big salt
works.
They're mining potash from the Dead Sea waters.
This is part of the potash works.
And the evaporation ponds for the potash works.
Same area potash.
And, uh, this is Marsab.
It's one of the holiest churches for eastern
orthodox Christians in
the hills above the Dead Sea, between Bethlehem
and the Dead Sea.
And this is a nude beach in Israel.
A lot of, umm, uh, Israelis will go to the
beach to the Dead Sea
because they believe that, umm, the mineral
water's good for psoriasis
because it's so low they say there's less
chance of getting skin
cancer because there's more atmosphere between
themselves and the sun.
I got arrested for taking this picture.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: They said, oh you're from
-- I got arrested for
taking pictures of naked women.
I said, no, no.
There weren't any women.
And I was showing them pictures of the men.
They said, oh, we don't care about the men.
We care about the women.
So they let me go.
>> [Silence]
George Steinmetz: These are sink holes on
the Israeli side of the
Dead Sea.
Because the water level drops the ground water
coming in from the
hills, umm, dissolves the salts that are -- one
of the layers in the
stratigraphy and then you get a cave-in as
the salts dissolved.
And this is in, umm, Waonamos.
It's an unusual volcanic formation in the
Libyan Sahara.
Salt lake in the Libyan Sahara.
Same kinda -- same situation you'd find in
China.
You can drink water out of your footprints
as you walk around the
lake.
But the lake here is totally sterile it's
so salty.
>> [Silence]
George Steinmetz: Sand dune field in Libya.
And you're getting over towards the Algerian
plateau.
You see one of our expedition cars in the
lower right.
I think that's that.
Are there any questions?
Yeah?
Pardon?
>> [Talking in the background]
George Steinmetz: I think you're supposed
to walk over to the
microphone.
>> [Talking in the background]
>> Hi.
Uh, the question was, how do you land?
You show the take-off but not so much the
landing.
George Steinmetz: Well, you, umm, landing
is -- takeoffs -- takeoffs
are optional.
Landings are mandatory.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: Umm, landings are a bit
of a -- the first couple
steps are kind of a skid mark.
As you first come in it's kinda like when
airplanes land you hear
the -- you know, the -- the -- the tire isn't
quite up to speed yet
and my first step is about the skid mark at
a foot -- about two or
three feet long.
It's a lot easier to land on sand.
If I land on asphalt it's very easy to stumble.
Or landing on a hard salt lake I don't really
like to do.
I'd much rather land on sand or kinda scuffy
terrain.
And I can -- I'm not the best lander but generally
I can land on
something about the size of a basketball court
and it's about three
steps to come to a complete stop if I'm lucky.
>> Sir, could you talk a little bit about
the power paraglider that
you use?
George Steinmetz: About the paraglider?
>> Uh-huh.
George Steinmetz: Well, it's kinda like a
motorcycle engine with a
big fan on the back.
It's kinda like the biggest leaf blower in
New Jersey and, umm, I
don't know.
It's, uh, uses -- my rig uses about 10 liters
of fuel and I can stay
in flight for two to three hours, depending
on the conditions, and it
weighs about 60 pounds.
With fuel probably, you know, 70, 80 pounds.
And it's a bit of a trick to take off and
once you're flying -- you're
self-stabilizing.
You're hanging underneath.
You kinda swing like you're in a playground
swing.
You get turbulence.
It's self-stabilizing so I can take pictures
with my hands off the
controls.
>> Sorry.
I'm relaying some questions from the San Francisco
office.
George Steinmetz: Okay.
>> And, uh, let's see.
So the question number one is, have you done
many shots from this
elevated angle before the series?
What made you want to take them all from this
perspective?
And then the third one is, how did the new
perspective change the way
you would frame photos?
Did it influence your style on the ground?
George Steinmetz: Umm, I've always liked taking
pictures from above
even, like, when I was a young guy traveling
in Africa.
Always wanted to climb a tree to take a picture.
Always liked kind of the elevated perspective.
But this aircraft it gives me kind of what
I think is kind of a
missing altitude, if there is such a thing,
in aerial photos.
Most people's aerial photos are very high
and, umm, usually like when
you're taking off in a plane like the really
cool view is when you're
just about to land.
And that's the kind of altitude I like to
fly in where it's, umm, you
get kind of a three dimensional quality to
the landscape, especially if you use a wide-angle
lens you can get a human sense of scale, you
can see,
you know, the vertical surfaces but you can
also see the horizontal
surfaces.
And I find it's just a much more interesting
space to be in.
I can get an aerial view where you can get
a sense of scale and human
perspective, umm, so, uh, and I -- it's a
problem for me when I go in
the field with my aircraft 'cause I tend to
wanna go flying every day.
It's fun to fly but it's also it's very expensive
to bring my rig over
there, and have the cars and all the support,
and I usually have these
French guys who wake up every morning and
they wanna go flying.
So it does influence my -- my work in that
I tend to take a lot more
aerial photos when I go out in the field with
my aircraft.
But when I'm working on the ground it's same
old same old.
>> I had a quick question about the logistics.
So you're talking about how you look for a
while on Google Earth and
you find a spot --
George Steinmetz: Yeah.
>> -- And just it seems -- it seems like in
all the photos that we saw
that would take a lifetime and a half to get
out there, seeing how the cars are so small.
What sort of considerations?
I mean, you find a spot you wanna take a photo
of and then do you
personally go from there to seeing if it's
accessible and seeing if it's
flyable like you're not in the lead of a big
mountain?
George Steinmetz: Generally like in a place
like the Empty Quarter a
big issue is could you get there?
And you go -- you can go at it a couple ways
you can go and say, you
know, what's easy to get to?
And you get to it and you look there.
But generally it's like going through the
lawn with a magnifying glass
and I'll try to find cool stuff and then say,
jeez, how can I get
there?
And sometimes you don't really know.
It's hard to know with what you're seeing
Google Earth what the
terrain is like.
Like the area in Saudi Arabia where you see
these enormous dunes that
are shaped like an egg crate and then the
salt flats you just don't
know if that's drivable.
And there's nobody to call to find out if
it's drivable.
And you go to Saudi Arabia and the locals
have never been out there
'cause you're the crazy son of a gun who wants
to go out there.
And they don't wanna go out there.
So there's a lot of issues.
In Libya we wanted to go out into the big
dune fields and we had a
driver that would come up with every excuse
not to go out there.
And finally I said, look, we're going out
there, dude.
And he got down and prayed.
This guy was not a very religious guy and
he was praying.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: And he was sure that he
was gonna die out there.
We got out there and look, there are tracks,
there are wrecked cars,
it's okay.
And he was still you know you know, he was
really nervous.
And so there are a lot of issues, political
issues, like permits and
when I wanted to go out into the salt deserts
in Iran, I had to get a
13-car escort from the Iranian military police
that are supposed to be
chasing after heroin smugglers and to have
13 cars and get a colonel
up there to protect the crazy American guy.
I mean, it's amazing that they let me out
there at all let alone to
give me a 13-car military escort, but I had
to organize all that to get
out to a place that I thought would be really
cool from Google Earth.
So you have all these different problems you
gotta worry -- and then,
like, wind conditions, and getting stuck in
the mud, and carburetors breaking and all
that other stuff.
Umm, and for some of the countries it's just
-- I mean, getting into
Libya or Iran, or -- it's really tough.
I'm going to Algeria next week.
Getting permission to fly aircraft like mine
in Algeria is not a
straightforward process.
It's a very non-linear process.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: Yes?
>> I'm just wondering so where would you like
to go?
Like what's your plans?
I didn't see Australia there.
Or what countries can't you go 'cause it's
too dangerous or it's too
hard to get into?
George Steinmetz: Well, I -- when I started
this project I looked at
some kind of old textbooks about deserts and
I got some maps and I
figured out all the different places that
I had to go to finish my project.
And right now my list I've got Algeria, which
I'm going next week, and
Egypt which is also very difficult for permission
to fly like flying
over the pyramids.
Not so easy to get permission.
And I need to go to Eritrea in Ethiopia and
then I'm pretty much
done.
I didn't go to Australia 'cause it's not dry
enough.
It gets more than ten centimeters and if you're
gonna be strict to the
rule hyper-arid it's too wet down there.
They get monsoonal rains and it's very dry
for most of the year but
when it rains they get hosed and it doesn't
really fit.
It's beautiful but it doesn't really fit.
Antarctica fits but Australia it's not on
the menu.
>> I was wondering if there was any sort of
magic that allows -- that
you use to be able to get to fly in these
places.
I mean, I'm a pilot.
I would love to fly some of these places.
Do you have to be with National Geographic
is that the magic ticket
or just lots of hard work?
George Steinmetz: There's nobody from National
Geographic here so I
can say honestly they don't really help at
all.
They -- they fund -- they fund -- they pay
for it which is wonderful
but in terms of access generally that's got
to be worked out.
I gotta work -- that's my problem.
Like going to Libya, I smuggle my aircraft
in and I had to work all
that stuff out.
And so, umm, and most of these places I mean,
they've never -- they
never heard of National Geographic.
>> So it's all -- this is your personal expertise?
You've slowly figured it out place by place?
George Steinmetz: Yeah.
It's like that's my cross to bear.
>> Okay.
George Steinmetz: Yeah. I mean, I love the
Geographic and
that -- you know, they publish the work and
they support it but they
don't know how to get an aircraft into Yemen.
They don't have to do it.
It's not their thing.
>> [Laughing]
>> Thanks.
George Steinmetz: They'll send me a letter
and I can use their
stationary but that's about it.
>> I'm just curious.
Which do you usually find is easier to get,
permission or forgiveness?
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: It's a lot easier to get
forgiveness.
There's a serious question because you have
to figure out, you know,
how to play the game and, like, in some African
buearacracy you try
and get permission and you're looking for
a world of pain.
And you just go out there and some guy might
get upset and, you know,
you give him like a case of beer out of the
back of the car and
everything's okay.
>> [Laughing]
George Steinmetz: It's hard to know how to
play that and in North
Africa it's really different because you're
between the European
buearacracy and kinda the free-living way
of Africa and so you kinda get the worst of
both worlds.
And I'm gonna find out more next week.
>> Hi, thanks for showing us very greatful
photos.
Can you tell us what kind of camera you use?
George Steinmetz: Yeah.
I try to keep it pretty simple while I'm flying
because it's awkward
changing lenses.
You get dust in 'em and stuff because I'm
in a very dusty environment
but you don't wanna be taking your hands off
the controls and have,
like -- there's no place to put anything.
It's basically like a flying lawn chair.
So, umm, I keep it real simple.
I usually have one body, sometimes two extra
lenses -- usually it's
one extra lens -- and I switched about five
years ago from film to
digital and that made my life a lot easier,
umm, because I can have
big CF cards so I don't have to change cassettes
in flight.
And, umm, the -- with digital imaging I can
use high ASA without any
loss of quality so I can take pictures in
really low light and I used
to have problems to use really fast lenses
and focusing it accurately
and now I can be kinda the pig and use autofocus
and I don't really
shoot like that but it's gotten a lot easier.
And the resolution is so much better.
I can get -- I can take pictures up and blow
them up the size of the
screen and they're just tack sharp and in
film they start to fall
apart once you get them much bigger than that.
So it's made life a lot easier.
>> So, one more question for the few pilot
and paraglider pilot geeks
in the audience.
Umm, you show up at this place and, I mean,
how much do you know about
the meteorology?
How much do you know about the conditions,
and are there local pilots
to show you if it's safe to fly and -- and
how do you --
George Steinmetz: No.No.
You're kind of going into virgin turf every
time and there aren't
no -- there aren't any local guides.
I mean, sometimes I'll go and maybe in a couple
South American
countries you can find somebody but generally
you're -- you're kinda
figuring it out on your own. And you can talk
to -- try and find guides
and say, you know, what are the winds like?
I've been going to the Sahara -- the Sahara's
divided into about ten
different countries and the only real season
for flying there is in
the fall because in the winter they get -- after
February/March they
get ripping winds, Harmattan winds that carve
the landsape if you look
at satellite imagery.
So there's really no -- only one season.
I got two or three months.
So I've missed my kids' birthdays every year
for ten years 'cause they're -- all
the birthdays are in the fall and I'm just,
sorry, Daddy's gone to the
Sahara.
That's the way it is.
It's the season.
It's like the surf's up and I gotta go.
But it's a real problem.
You try and ask -- you go to a place like
the Empty Quarter you try and
ask 'cause you look at this landscape and
you can see they've got huge
winds.
I can tell by looking at the dunes.
I know what direction they're coming from.
I just don't know what time of year they might
be down and to get
around up there safely you have to be there
when the temperatures are
relatively cool so that the cars don't overheat
so you don't have to
carry literally a ton of water.
And so if you go down you can walk outta there.
So you wanna be down in the winter in, uh,
a stable atmosphere.
But it's very hard to -- there aren't any
meteorological stations out
there so that's tough.
It's been a big problem.
And sometimes I went to, like, Morocco and
it was winter and we got
hosed.
It was bad weather for three weeks and somebody
said, you know, it's
snowing in, I don't know, in Whatchamacallit.
I said, well, where in the hell is Whatchamacallit?
Gad zukes.
There was snow there on the palm trees.
It was fantastic.
We had, you know, one good day in three weeks.
It's like that sometimes.
It's tough.
Any other questions in.
>> Umm, is there any chance or possiblity
to make some of those great
pictures available for Google Earth?
George Steinmetz: Yeah.
Actually, I'm working on making a layer and,
uh, things that
will -- gonna be plugged into Google Earth.
So -- Google Earth it's been an amazing, uh,
resource for me and
'cause it's just the whole world, and it's
searchable.
And you can look at it in time.
I had a problem when I first started using
Google Earth when it was in
its infancy and I'd look at an area and it
didn't tell me what date
the picture was taken in.
So I'd try and go there and the picture was
taken in the winter and I
was going there in the summer and the pictures
didn't match up.
And now it's just there's so much more information
there.
It's a really amazing resource so I'm happy
to give something back.
Well, thank you all for coming.
>> [Applause]